osi bonds bi people have to do
on to set of r
To be honest, I'm a little nervous
. It's been a while since I've done a shoot like this, so I'm a
little nervous because I have to speak a little English, so I think it
'll be fun.
I'll try
to answer it in a curious, honest and very serious manner,
so make sure to
wash the star MV and the sent me form is
rp rai long, etc. sta ooo
one source Sam is um, eye pencil
brener keuk bottled water in mon flo a,
deuce age sales a with him
My dream changed a lot when I was young and in clothes, I
really
wanted to become a marathon runner, and I wanted to become a soccer player and scientist just like this
.
Turing Wonil Crying should
metaphor you can't give it nomal
nex1 sall stimuli february
primus out flip 2g weakness
when hating or socks on twitter
but pens fight laos clothes buttons a lot of
out all of a sudden a
bunch of little kids come and go
14 days  With this,
one of them writes bi No, I was surprised
, he hugged me and recognized me. But still, that
young height dreamed of my son now I always
dreamed that my younger friends recognized me.
intro dual
pulse saturday May again laugh ifla
once said for April wolsong
Manny and things are de
uh oh oh three fry Samsung didn't
even do that, so you really
can't even imagine that the airport was so full
I was so surprised
I had a little bit of joy  I was really bewildered
, and that was really impressive
, uh, maybe I won't be able to find it for the rest of my life,
pls play the answer
I was born to Mr. Shil. My place is a comfortable
style 3 srm practice 1 ear
work striker time gesture male
group woona or
something I really wanted to try to imitate their bounce rhythm
So I had practice while looking in the mirror
and following the verse by myself.
I remember practicing like this ah I saw
Laos Coop in front of an air
bum u I can’t look at it too much y ah oh bongsan
3i included if r3 play
kid kmi one song in my heart
Breath Ding id's morning america
ties grand mic of fr scout
couple singer mermaid gas spring
why me like we give korean amen uni
fort prostitute show count boo hangul day
mach bs go mover vs
cow rural ten I'm not hungry
I laughed again at the spit cut. Actually, I
also really like concerts where I can perform like this. I
can connect with these fans and receive this
action right away, so
I feel really here.
Sue again wish sda soa 1 let's use ring
ahhh mandae pulse tom february
stars truck that kid's tablo hyung
I wonder if it will be gone
I really like that digital camera’s song like a bought horse, so I’m still
being honored with it, and Blue 0
takes care of you a lot.
I actually got a call today. Is it okay?
I want to express my gratitude in my fall, when the rain is
already raining bls plus
episode 6 cause Yulha, etc.
When subtracting a day in won, it’s a very script
mouse. You’re a professional or one a
shell delicious. When you explain this why
Juice  Not 2 Te Homes,
but 10 Out Lument Pulse Muses
Must-have Display Shoe Nim I really
like the Beatles, so
I listened to
them all over the country from early to last.  I think the message conveyed by the music, the very
comfortable melody and that vibe gave me
a lot of inspiration.
Wake of Face Tone
Gochujang Kimchi Fries 7 can't
let fl I've tried chicken in various countries,
but there are
things that I can't explain
.
I was very happy and thankful because it seemed like an experience that allowed me to tell stories that I had never done before.
Thank you Burst
[Music]